[Applause]
all right
Tim Allen's decade sold Antics caught
into question in 2023 with this clip of
the Home Improvement star flashing his
on-screen wife Patricia Richardson
surfacing online after Pamela Anderson
alleged the actor exposed himself to her
on set of the sitcom Pam got a minute it
started on Monday after variety
published an excerpt from Anderson's
upcoming Memoir in which she recalls
Alan flashing her during her time on the
show Pamela was the original Tool Time
girl in seasons one and two
Thank you Lisa Allen says the incident
never happened though telling ET quote I
would never do such a thing but then
this outtake went viral oh
baby you look great while the credits
roll Alan wearing a kilt lifts up his
costume
except it's not what it looks like
Richardson speaking out to set the
record straight telling E.T Allen was
well dressed under there adding quote I
was just shocked that he lifted The Kilt
but not by a man in boxer shorts as for
Anderson's story it wasn't on camera so
there's no proof it happened but she
does recall it in detail in her book
going back to her first day of filming
actually in the pilot I was wearing
cutoffs you know my tool belts Anderson
alleges quote I walked out of my
dressing room and Tim was in the hallway
in his robe he opened his robe and
flashed me quickly completely naked
underneath our little Pammy and she's
the sweetest girl that's why we love her
at the time Anderson was 23 years old
best known for appearing in Playboy they
called me they wanted me to do a cover
first so I did the October 89 cover and
they wanted me to be a playmate and she
claims that after Allen exposed himself
quote he said it was only fair there
because he had seen me naked now we were
even I laughed uncomfortably Pam's been
through a zillion miles since she left
Home Improvement when did you realize
that you two would have this magical
chemistry immediately I loved him I like
talking about my feelings
because you make me oh both actresses
opened up to Etsy about what Alan was
like behind the scenes Tim hasn't
changed I haven't changed he's just so
like modest about his success and such a
real person and a lot of fun to make fun
of you know poke fun at me
doesn't take a genius to fix a hair
dryer that's why we asked you
love being Tim Taylor he Taylor's family
he loved being him and Tim Allen had a
horrible life of being famous and
everybody wanting something from him and
pushing him and Tim Taylor was this
heavily married man with his great boys
and great life and so he wanted that
show to go on forever